ahora vamos a usar el clip de papel
vamos a desdoblar lo lo desdoblamos y
puedes dejar este gancho ajá también del
otro lado puedes dejar pero queremos que
tenga esta longitud entonces vamos a
cortar el exceso de este lado
ahí está ahora vamos a doblar lo vamos a
doblarlo y vamos a pasarlo
por aquí por por el estuche de batería
aquí abajo del cable rojo y después
vamos a enderezar estas partes
enderezamos esta parte
y
también está ahí así debe quedar ahora
para que los motores queden en una buena
posición vamos a doblar un poco los
clips aquí de los extremos
entonces los dobles hacia abajo y
también intenté que quede simétrico para
que quede mejor ahora vamos a jalar
estos cables hacia atrás quitarlos del
camino y
y entonces bueno para el buen
funcionamiento voy a doblar un poco más
esto y después vamos a
vamos ahora con el pegamento caliente
entonces ya quedó ahí bien doblado como
lo quiero
y ahora pongo un poco de pegamento
caliente en medio entonces voy a poner
aquí un poco de pegamento bueno de hecho
bastante se va a necesitar así así debe
quedar el pegamento caliente los
sostienes por por un rato hasta que
seque queda en posición y listo ahora
tomar algo de tiempo porque es bastante
pegamento el que colocamos aquí entonces
bueno tardará algo de tiempo en enfriar
este pegamento y bueno lo pusimos sobre
plástico el plástico es un aislante
entonces no no enfriará muy rápido pero
cuando obtenga un color medio blanco
entonces ya estará frío así que espera
un momento mientras sostengo en su lugar
una vez que haya enfriado el pegamento
tú puedes ya pegar los motores entonces
para pegar los motores debes asegurarte
de que los conductores de cobre éstos
queden hacia arriba
ahora vamos a voltear esto
el clip y el motor deben quedar así
el motor debe quedar perpendicular al
estuche de baterías y así debe quedar
esto entonces bueno sostén lo en su
lugar
debe haber un buen contacto entre el
clip y el motor y ahora si puedes poner
silicón caliente
asegúrate de que no se mueva que quede
simétrico
y pon silicón caliente en ambos lados
del clip
lo bueno del pegamento caliente en esta
situación es que enfriará mucho más
rápido que cuando lo colocamos sobre el
estuche de baterías
el metal del motor actúa como un
disipador de calor entonces se enfría
era mucho más rápido y ya que está frío
a un lado colocas también pegamento
sobre el otro clip y el otro motor de la
misma manera y esperas a que enfríe
una vez que ya el pegamento en frío en
los motores puedes doblarlos hacia abajo
y esto formará lo que son los pies de tu
de tu robot sports deben doblarse tal
que el robot tenga una pequeña caída
hacia atrás jaja debe quedar así
y bueno asegúrate de que queden
simétricos ambos motores a la misma
distancia